hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of stuff happening today you may
have seen the news that Bryan Singer is
leaving the x-men franchise and Fox is
considering a total reboot of its
universe continuity is a mess in the
x-men films Wolverine is going to be
changing forever when Hugh Jackman
leaves the franchise and even Deadpool
which should be a sure bet for them is
starting to crack at the seams a little
bit with creative differences behind the
scenes so they're just considering
wiping the slate clean and redoing
things just like they did when they did
x-men first class so you have to
remember that the original Bryan Singer
x-men movie was in the year 2000 so I
mean they've been developing it for a
couple years before that so late 90s to
a 2000 premiere they rebooted things
with first class in 2011 so it was a
little over 10 years for them to
completely try and reboot their universe
but then they backtracked a little bit
with Days of Future past because of all
their pre-existing actors like Hugh
Jackman some of whom were still really
popular at the box office so I'll talk
about that in a second because I think
that's led to a lot of the problems
they're having right now where you have
the old guard that's still very popular
in their own right but aging very fast
in the new guard that you're trying to
get off the ground so that you can plan
for the next 10 years so the Fox
franchises are eating up track before
people can lay it down in front of them
so the train is basically going off the
rails but the big second wind has been
Deadpool it was so successful and it's a
brand new thing for them at least in
this continuity I mean they've kind of
rebooted Wolverine Origins so that
version of Deadpool doesn't exist
anymore but I think the Deadpool Days of
Future past McEvoy vs. Stewart joke that
Ryan Reynolds did is a good example of
how big a mess their timeline is in how
just wiping the slate clean can fix all
that so what's the deal with Bryan
Singer supposedly he's leaving the
franchise what will probably happen is
is that he'll give them some creative
tips along the way he won't just go off
to an island in the middle of the ocean
and never speak to anyone again he's
just doing the Christopher Nolan thing
where he feels like he's creatively done
with the franchise so he wants to step
away I would
bet that Warner Brothers even though
Christopher Nolan isn't working on any
of the DC films in any capacity they
still go to him for advice on new stuff
they're doing like there's no way that
Ben Affleck did not ask Christopher
Nolan for some helpful hints when he's
making this new Batman film so that's
probably what Bryan Singer's gonna do
going forward he can still make good
films I just feel like creatively he's
burnt out on x-men IP so what they
should probably be doing is is finding
their own version of Geoff Johns to sort
of chair the studio and Shepherd all
these comic book films so that they can
be in the same continuity but all
retained the tone that they need to for
each of their films and fun x-men fact
we talked about Kevin Feige all the work
that he's done with Marvel how
successful they've been Kevin Feige
'he's very first job in hollywood was as
a low-level executive producer on the
original Bryan Singer 2000 x-men film he
said that when he saw the first raw cut
of the film the first raw edit he
thought that it would end his career in
Hollywood forever
little did he know cut to now he's one
of the most powerful people in Hollywood
so just goes to show you how things can
go down so like a Deadpool movie is
always gonna be very different from one
of the main x-men films x-men films tend
to be Family Affairs just like Captain
America Civil War the big Marvel films
but then you have characters like
Wolverine who are better served by a
slightly more hardcore darker tone so
that's the real challenge the same thing
is happening with DC Comics like can we
make some films super serious you know
Batman does really well when his films
are dark and gritty Superman does not so
Fox just needs to find the point of
crossover so here's my first big idea
for Fox just wiping the slate clean so
there's always been a question about who
has the rights to the King character he
was a really big part of apocalypses
origin story so it was kind of a bummer
that he was left out of the x-men
apocalypse movie but I feel like if Fox
and Marvel can come to a sharing
arrangement spider-man style they can
let Fox use the Kane character who is a
time traveler who can just completely
reboot their universe just mess with
their timeline using time-travel so they
can still do Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
movies they can recast the Wolverine
role
do x-23 I'll talk about that in a second
because Wolverine is like another big
franchise that exists by itself and then
you can recast some of the main x-men
characters and retool that universe so
that it's all in the same continuity
because I feel like audiences are very
forgiving of reboots as long as the new
thing you give them is amazing which is
easier said than done
so I'd be totally happy if they just did
not do another x-men film for at least a
couple more years while they figure this
out they can continue making the
Deadpool movies unchanged so the least
have that going on even if they don't
have x-men films going on and then they
can wait a couple more years to
reintroduce the Wolverine franchise with
a recast version of the Logan character
and x-23 just to build themselves out
room for the future because I think if
you're gonna relaunch the x-men universe
you really need to have like a 10-15
year plan Marvel tends to think of it in
phases fox needs to have an idea for
their big arcs where they like things to
go even if they have to change their
plans down the line and it sounds like
since first class dropped back in 2011
they didn't have that plan so the lack
of planning has caused this complete
mess now but like I said the Deadpool
franchise is still doing really well
they're already planning sequels beyond
the second Deadpool movie you know like
they're introducing cable and Deadpool
to cable Domino maybe a couple other
characters they've already said that
they're developing Deadpool 3 just you
know ideas for the movie they want to
introduce x-force in that which I feel
like is a good move for them and if
x-force ends up being a big thing they
can spin that off into its own franchise
too they already talked about New
Mutants but that wasn't mentioned in
this big universe reboot but I'd be
willing to bet that if they're gonna be
rebooting the x-men films then they'll
postpone New Mutants until they get this
all figured out but it's a huge deal
I'll be really curious to see if this
ever happens to Marvel they sound like
they have a plan for Robert Downey jr.
Chris Evans the other a-list Avengers
leaving the franchise recasting roles
but you don't really know until you get
there like they say they have a lot of
time before they have to worry about
that Disney and Marvel or machines when
it comes to planning ahead they have
really deep pockets so I don't think
it's gonna be too hard for them to keep
actors around and I definitely feel like
Fox could benefit from a Geoff Johns
Kevin Feige type person who really
understands the comic book characters
the origins of the characters even if
they change things for the movies who
can bring about a unifying creative
vision for the larger universe that also
allows them to do say like Deadpool
movies that get to be their own thing
Wolverine movies they get to be their
own thing in x-men films that kind of
bring everything together so you just
can't really do that unless you have
someone that's powerful enough like
Kevin Feige to make those decisions and
say this is what we're gonna be doing
with these characters this is what the
tone is gonna be like let's find a
director to bring that vision about so
let me know what do you think about the
idea of a complete x-men Fox Universe
reboot now don't forget the Fantastic
Force in there too I should have
mentioned them but that's also a
franchise that's desperately in need of
revitalizing so there's just so many
reasons why they should reboot their
universe I think it's just a question of
whether or not they're gonna pull the
trigger in how much that's going to
affect the stuff that they're already
working on right now like the Deadpool
sequel you know relatively minor I think
I think they're far enough along a
Deadpool development that they're just
gonna let that be its own thing and then
for Deadpool 3x4 stuff they'll try to
like slowly leave that in with whatever
it's happening with the x-men at that
time but that would be like somewhere in
the early 2020s so that's still a long
ways off so it's not like everybody's
packing up in burning the bridge on the
way out Homer Simpson style but you will
probably hear about big x-men changes
throughout the rest of the year and
early in next year like they tend to
figure those big things out first then
once they hire the right people then
they'll start making announcements like
hey this is what's gonna be happening
with the x-men franchise they'll
probably wait to talk about their
Wolverines succession plan until well
after the Wolverine movie comes out like
they want Hugh Jackman to go out in
style so don't expect to hear too much
about them recasting the Logan Wolverine
for a long time but what will happen is
is I'll be doing more Deadpool videos
towards the end of the year they're
really close to locking down their
director it's probably going to be the
John wick director that we talked about
a couple weeks ago so there'll be a
bunch more Deadpool bonus videos for the
rest of the year be sure to subscribe to
get everything
later tonight there's a new arrow
episode so that's gonna be my next video
to post well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn why the
Deadpool 2 director left and you can
click here to learn
all about Young Justice season 3 which
is just confirmed thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you